el 60% de los lagos de turquía se han
secado en los últimos 50 años tal como
este el tus golf o el lago salado solía
ser el segundo más grande del país las
principales razones son los métodos de
cultivo ilegales el descenso de las
precipitaciones y el aumento de las
temperaturas tres factores que han
tomado fuerza en los últimos años ha
habido hasta years
y el lago salado es el ejemplo perfecto
de las consecuencias del cambio
climático espero que podamos traer a las
autoridades para que entiendan la
situación para que comprendan cómo hemos
llegado hasta aquí porque lo que vemos
es lo que ocurre cuando los agricultores
deciden seguir cultivando cereales que
necesitan mucha agua y si seguimos así
no habrá más líquido en los alrededores
ni siquieran las represas según el
presidente turco el acceso al agua
potable será uno de los mayores retos de
la humanidad en los próximos años la
creciente lucha contra la sequía es una
de las razones por las que finalmente
turquía terminó por ratificar el acuerdo
de parís cinco años después que el resto
de los países pero con una condición que
se le considere un país el desarrollo lo
que le permitiría acceder a las últimas
tecnologías y sobre todo a la
financiación climática